i try and
temper
creativity with being very deliberate
and so i watched a lot of filmmaking
friends before me
go to sundance
get a similar call
and not have the next project
pete i understand the first movie that
you wrote and directed got into sundance
yeah so i mean i guess it's the first
one
that i put out to film festivals um it's
a short film i did called 3d
it was my
senior thesis film coming out of nyu
film school so it's kind of like
you know if you were an undergraduate
film and you were like
crazy enough to say i'm a director like
this was uh
the path and so um did a 24-minute short
film that i wrote produced directed
had to raise 24 000 to make this film
um it was a different time because we
had to shoot on film
so
everything was
it i mean people who have never shot on
film have no
have no
budgetary appreciation for what that
meant
and
the example i often use is that uh
we had to do an answer print so
um
you know
like when you used to develop film
photographs you
develop and then you get the negative
back
uh in the little pouch with the photos
right
um and you could continue to develop
those that negative again and again if
you needed to and so that's how we were
making films we had the negative
um but we had a work print and so we
would cut the work print but save the
negative and then when the work print
was finished we'd cut well not us
there'd be a negative cutter with white
gloves and glue
who would cut the
actual negative that ran through the
camera and then cemented back together
to match the
[Music]
locked picture from the work print
and then that cemented negative that it
runs through the camera all the film
that i run through the camera now
cemented together
in the you know
configuration of the film
that's from that's the
print from which the
that's the
film from which the prints get made
and so anyhow
that cost four thousand dollars for the
negative cut
and now you could i've made shorts for
that amount of money you know and so um
anyhow that uh that film starred
dorian misik who
i was an actor i've met uh during my nyu
days and it's gone on to be in
four or five of my projects um starred
carrie washington right at the beginning
of
her career fresh out of george
washington she was graduating same year
i did
al thompson myself
and it went to sundance in about 30
festivals around the world
and so did you
actually think that you could get into
something i mean were you thinking this
is well just it's a wild card
i mean that's the thing i think over
time
what
it's nice to know
for me it was nice to know that there
were these potential
um
outlets for a project
but i never did the projects for those
outlets
so it was always enough for me to finish
something
um that was kind of the point um now
that's not
removing the reality that
i am aware that these outlets exist but
it's like this kind of filmmaker
zen balancing act of like
if i put all my weight on
acknowledgement from some outside group
then if i don't get that well what is
that going to do for me emotionally on
this end you know will i feel like i
failed will i feel frustrated will i
become embittered you know so
i didn't expect it i knew it could
happen
and when it did happen
i felt like
i had achieved something that was pretty
difficult um
and so i was very happy about that but
that's kind of been that's been the
journey of the whole career like how do
you navigate
um
what you want
from
what's
achievable
and what can you guarantee about this
work that you do
so you don't you know find yourself
becoming one of those people who are
just
angry at how the industry has
not recognized them for what they think
is great work
what was the submission for you at that
time
um you know what
i have a pretty good memory it was
probably like 45
and it was probably like
you know 45 i didn't have
you know but uh that was i mean that was
always part of your
budgeting too like how much are we going
to put aside for
film festival submissions um but it was
either it was either 35 or 45 dollars
i'm pretty sure
and so no kickstarter no seed and spark
no indiegogo at that time no no
and how did you raise that you said 24
000 24 000. so i i raised the portion
from someone i had interned with um i
raised the portion from my mom a small
portion i raised a portion from
just knocking on doors and you know hey
remember remember you
put those braces on me you know
well
you look like you might have a little
bit of you know money so uh it was kind
of by hooker crook you know i worked
um and you know it took it took a long
time um to put it all together the film
kind of sat around for a while until
post-production money could be
raised
did you go to sundance with the film i
did yeah yeah i did okay so when you
packed up to leave sundance what was
your mindset thinking like okay now
things are really going to change for me
right yeah i mean i think
you know that that's the thing right you
kind of get into this place where you
you
like almost everything i've said to you
i could i could then you know shake the
etch a sketch and erase it all because
you try and temper yourself with this
you know healthy
view of expectations and then you get
into the thing and you're like okay
maybe this is it now
um and so
yeah i think at that time i was
definitely
um
hopeful
and
expectant of certain things to come out
of it because i had watched other people
have a have a particular kind of journey
after going to sundance
and then you got back home and so you're
in new york city or new jersey in new
jersey okay yeah
and and what happened
um so get back home i get a phone call
from uh lynn auerbach who
um worked at the sundance institute
she was interested in seeing if i had a
feature or anything you know like what
was my next project
luckily i did and so i passed that
feature script on her
i've been very strategic because i'm i'm
i often
i try and
temper
creativity with being very deliberate
and so i watched a lot of filmmaking
friends before me
go to sundance
get a similar call
and not have the next project
and you know they say oh we'll reach out
when you know you finish that script but
like
if you take eight months to reach out
well
the likelihood that they've reached out
to a new batch of people who had a
you know great film at another film
festival is high and i think you just
want to when that doorbell rings you
want to answer the door as far as i'm
concerned and so
um
i
got her that script it wasn't really you
know ready or perfect in any way
had fade in and fade out and about 113
pages in between and so um she read it
um
she was like well i don't think we're
gonna i don't think this is gonna be the
one but get me another draft that was
all i needed so um we did that dance for
maybe a year and a half
um before
they were like well look we're not going
to
select the film but we'll introduce you
to a bunch of producers in la
and set you up with meetings and so that
was kind of the evolution of that what
did that experience teach you
so the experience of
going to sundance and then coming home
and then the phone not ringing like uh
off the hook
um
well in the book i talk about
uh
after that
screening at nyu's film festival
um and and again taking a lot of that
expectation
of certain acknowledgement that i had at
sundance and bringing it back home to
to the university um we had a film
festival that
was uh designed to screen all the work
of all the students that finished the
project
and so um
they would have a craft award and they
would have uh
like a wasserman finalist so top three
undergrad films top three grad films
and um
the film didn't get recognized in any
way whatsoever in any of the categories
and i
and it had been advertised though as
you know a film to see or look at how
how well our
slate of films is doing you know here
are these
six films from this year that went to
sundance including you know 3d et cetera
et cetera and so um
after
the awards kind of came and went i had a
meeting with the dean at the time
um or the chair rather
and i was like look how does this happen
you know it's kind of crazy to me this
is this is
righteous indignant me uh at what 22
years old you know it's kind of crazy to
me that uh
you're using the film to promote the
festival and how well you know
the work is in the festival but then
with these awards it's like crickets or
whatever
and he explained to me that well in the
past we've had a film win sundance then
come back and not be acknowledged in the
way we're talking about so i was like
all right
and i didn't win you know i get it um
and
my takeaway from
all of that was
i can either be upset about this which
it's clearly becoming
evident that i'd be
standing on very unfirm ground with this
anger
what i'm taking away from this is that
i've never made i never took the
opportunity to build a network of people
who are aware
of me
you know as
um you know a student
to watch or someone that they had
had a more personal relationship with
and so
coming out of that
both sundance and nyu film festival i
was pretty committed to never having
that happen again and so building a
community of folks who would be aware of
me and know my story and be clear on
where i wanted to go with my career
and that's how i you know built my
production company
rinse repeat i think that's how i got
into television directing which was not
just like a you know
i decided to do it and and it happened
it was very um
deliberate and took a lot of time and a
lot of relationship building and so
much like the phone call job you know
there was this great takeaway from from
those two film festival experiences that
i think
i'm not where i am today had i not gone
through them
and so did you actually go on meetings
did you fly out to la oh yeah during
that time you did i went out to
i went out to nyu i went out to la in
june of o2 um and i had i don't know
maybe 15 meetings set
and uh you know
i stumbled my way through these meetings
i did the best i could i don't
looking back i probably was full of
passion but maybe not didn't know how to
run a good meeting uh present myself in
like meeting form
and uh
you know the takeaway from the trip was
well
it looks like
the film is maybe a little too
mainstream
for what the sundance institute was
looking to do
and then on the flip it looks like it's
a little too endy for what these more
mainstream producers at the time in 2002
are looking to do and let's just
pause and say it's a
vastly different landscape for content
in o2 it's like you had you had movies
made at studios or mini majors
and then you had like
two or three indies that fought through
and made it out it was a it was not this
kind of
world where you see all these
independent films and you could put them
out on whatever platform you want or you
could make them for cheap enough that
you know you could self-distribute them
through your website or something
and so um
yeah i brought that back and said well
i'm gonna
if it's not gonna work for either of
these two
demographics or buckets or whatever we
want to call
then
looks like i'm gonna have to raise some
money on my own
and that was um that was my that game
that be that became my focus after that
trip
and so not indie enough for sundance how
does that happen what
well i think i think it all i think it
changes
with the times you know like i think
every festival slate if you look at any
festival year to year there's kind of a
theme that happens just that kind of
reflects the times and i think in 2002
um
you know
the the the
premise and the execution of the film
was not
necessarily like
leaning toward the types of
character exploration that might have
been
more of the of the day as far as like
this is what an indie film is going to
do and all and all of these things are
like shifting terms you know so that's
another thing for like filmmakers to
to always remember like these things can
shift
they and blow in the wind they change
with with the times i mean
i've done tv shows where
one year they say we will never hire a
first-time director
um you know when i was in route when i
was trying to get my first jobs and then
two seasons later
people i know are getting their first
ever episode of tv on the same show
and you know things things are free to
change but it's like just knowing like
it's all so
malleable it's also
um
you know nothing is set in stone
so do you think that
if you had been the same age then now
and gotten into sundance that it would
be more difficult because you talked
about building a network well there was
no social media
back then
yeah no no myspace even right so yeah it
was
nothing right email was your social
network right
aol yeah you've got mail right right
right so
do you think it'd be more difficult or
do you think it was actually easier then
because there were less people trying to
do it that's a great question um
so i think it was easier then
you know i would say it was
not easier than
while there may have been
it may have been more difficult to
it definitely was more difficult to make
something
and now
that means there are probably fewer
things being made
but conversely i think because the
barriers to entry are lower now and it's
kind of been there's been a
democratization to like getting in the
game
um
you've got
fewer things
being made in the past with poor
execution
and then you've got more things being
made now
but with
people who have the opportunity to
execute well
because it's not like their first thing
ever you know what i mean and i remember
when i when i saw like friends brothers
um like from my year of high school like
one friend's brother i'm thinking
specifically was like in middle school
it was doing like green screen stuff you
know what i mean it's like i hadn't even
done it yet i was like 24 i'd never
green screened anything yet and this
kid's in middle school green screen and
stuff so you you take that and you just
move along the timeline
of like now that person's 22 with a
short film
that the like the possibility for that
short film to be so much more well
executed than what i was making i think
is
high